with its small town setting and
fresh-faced young lead dc's star girl is
probably the sweetest superhero show
ever made which is why her dark history
of murdered family members older
boyfriends and more might surprise you
since she was first introduced as the
new star-spangled kid in 1999's stars
and stripe number zero courtney whitmore
has been treated with great affection by
her comic book creators this is due to
the fact that her writer jeff johns
based courtney's personality appearance
and name after his sister courtney johns
in several interviews about star girl
jon spoke of the real-life courtney's
quote spirit and optimistic energy that
i wanted to put back in the world with
star girl tragically courtney johns died
in the twa flight 800 disaster of 1996.
her comic book counterpart became a
tribute to her real world inspiration
and courtney johns was even memorialized
in the pilot episode of stargirl by
placing an edited image of her in a
photo alongside star girl actress breck
bassinger
in the star girl tv show pat dugan
played by luke wilson is courtney
whitmore's stepfather and the former
sidekick to the superhero star man
played by joel mchale together the two
fought crime in the early 21st century
before starman was killed and dugan semi
retired in the comics dugan served as
the sidekick stripesy to the
star-spangled kid during world war ii
the pair eventually joined the seven
soldiers of victory who were scattered
throughout time after a battle with
nebula man dugan wound up in ancient
egypt where he was enslaved and forced
to work on the pyramids until members of
the justice league of america rescued
him and brought him back to the present
dugan eventually found love with
courtney's mother barbara and took on
the mantle of the armored hero stripe
when his adopted daughter decided to
become a new star-spangled kid while his
new life came with plenty of challenges
he's probably glad he didn't have to die
in ancient egypt
while most people accept that courtney
whitmore is a smart and capable young
woman eager to help others embrace the
best sides of themselves she didn't
start out that way in fact in her early
appearances she came across as an
entitled brat who gets into the
superhero life for the most selfish of
reasons to screw with her stepfather's
life in the original stars and stripes
series courtney discovers the original
star-spangled kid's gear and her
stepfather's belongings and uses it to
create her own version of the
star-spangled kids costume and promptly
starts getting into trouble courtney
even attempts to use her knowledge of
dugan's superhero past to get her mother
to leave him luckily dugan and courtney
gradually form a closer relationship and
courtney's experiences as star girl help
her mature eventually she admits that
she became a superhero for the wrong
reasons and that her stepfather was born
with a moral compass that she had to
learn how to develop for herself
superheroes need to know how to take
care of themselves on the battlefield
this is particularly true of young
superheroes whose inexperience might get
them killed however courtney whitmore
often displays such a violent streak in
her fights that readers are left feeling
almost sorry for her enemies in stars
and stripe number one courtney meets a
school bully on the first day at her new
high school and decides to kick him in
the face when he starts mouthing off
another issue actually shows courtney
kicking a bad guy in the crotch during a
battle and relishing the opportunity to
use such dirty fighting tactics to be
fair many of the foes star girl faces
off against are homicidal and courtney
probably does need to use such extreme
force in certain fights still her hair
trigger temper does drive her to fight
nastily and her early appearances making
her seem like a super powered delinquent
hey
somebody's messing with your car
family relationships can be tough for
superheroes and star girl is no
exception in fact courtney whitmore's
birth father sam curtis just gets worse
in each of his appearances in a scene
from stars in stripe number 14 that was
adapted for the tv show sam shows up at
courtney's house on her birthday and
cons her out of a valuable locket
claiming he needs to help a non-existent
brother while courtney sees through the
con she hands over the locket anyway
crushed by her dad's selfish cruelty
later courtney discovers sam has joined
the super villain group the royal flush
gang under the alias two of clubs during
the infinite crisis storyline she's
informed that sam is dead and decides
she doesn't want to waste her time
hating a dead man who never reformed
instead she accepts that pat dugan is
the real father figure in her life and
chooses to identify as his daughter
courtney whitmore met her original arch
nemesis cindy berman aka shiv in high
school during the stars and stripes
series in fact cindy was the captain of
the cheerleading squad and a variation
of the popular mean girl trope sounds
like a fun way to explore high school
rivalries in a superhero setting right
well not so much turns out cindy was the
daughter of the dragon king a crime boss
who tortured and experimented on her to
make her a living weapon despite cindy's
pleas the dragon king regularly had
cybernetic implants installed in her
often without any anesthesia choosing to
focus all of her anger and pain on
courtney cindy attacked her superhero
counterpart with a homicidal rage born
from a life of constant abuse her tragic
story is so intriguing that the star
girl television series made it a major
plotline in season one as portrayed by
meg de lacy cindy shiv is frightening
and truly abhorrent but you can't help
feeling sorry for her at the same time
superheroes and super villains tend to
be connected by shared tragedy and these
two are no different in stars and stripe
issues 12 and 13 the dragon king used
mind control to turn the youth of blue
valley against the adult the
brainwashing even worked on courtney
until she managed to shake off its
effects distracting the dragon king long
enough for the superhero shining knight
to battle the villain during the fight
the dragon king fell off his flying
dragon and died in an explosion shiv who
was still obsessed with making her
father proud blamed courtney for the
dragon king's death and swore to kill
courtney and everyone she cared about
although courtney's actions were only
indirectly responsible for the dragon
king's fall shiv's interpretation of the
events earned the future star girl an
archenemy ironically in the star girl tv
series cindy stabs her father in the
back in retaliation for locking her up
nevertheless she continues to see star
girl as her enemy and continues looking
to take her down
the path of true love never runs
smoothly for superheroes and that's
definitely true for star girl who found
herself falling for billy batson a 16
year old boy who worked alongside her
with the justice society of america
nothing wrong with that right
well not quite as fans of the movie
shazam know billy batson is the teenage
alter ego of the superhero shazam or
captain marvel as he was known at the
time who looks like he's in his late 20s
or early 30s this made it look like
captain marvel was flirting with an
underage girl when they were hanging out
with the justice society of america
although the two only actually dated
when billy was in his teenage form the
rest of the jsa who were unaware of
captain marvel's true identity called
him out on the seemingly inappropriate
nature of their relationship
star girl's first major romance might
have been rough but her second was
downright tragic following billy
batson's departure courtney found
herself developing feelings for albert
rothstein aka adam smasher al eventually
reciprocated but he later fell under the
influence of black adam who convinced
him to invade the oppressed country of
kandak and kill its dictator president
putting him in direct conflict with the
jsa in the ensuing battle al sacrifices
himself to save the people of kandak
from the spectre but a distraught black
adam is able to revive him almost
immediately back home al is put on trial
for his actions and pleads guilty but
courtney never one to give up promises
she'll be there for him when he gets out
making matters more difficult there's an
actual age difference between courtney
and albert although that doesn't seem to
matter in a possible future where an
adult courtney is married to albert
audiences can also look forward to
seeing noah centeno play adam smasher in
the 2022 black adam movie alongside
dwayne the rock johnson as black adam
although considering their comic book
history this might not be so great for
adam smasher
at the core of star girl's appeal is her
amazing family dynamic few sidekicks are
older than the main hero but stripes
relationship with star girl is made
special by the fact that pat dugan is
courtney's stepfather and became a
superhero to support and look out for
her in fact courtney regularly sees her
family as the inspiration for her
superhero activities which is why it was
so traumatizing for her to see them all
murdered before her eyes this happened
in jsa number 68 when the red morgue
went back in time and slaughtered
courtney's entire family as they were
all having breakfast luckily time master
rip hunter arrived soon after to save
courtney rip helped assemble a team of
jsa members to travel to different
points in time to erase the events
leading up to the dugan whitmore
family's murder and set things right
saving the universe and leading a double
life can be tough on a person's mental
health but one adventure saw star girl
literally land in an insane asylum
during the events of the black vengeance
jsa storyline courtney traveled back in
time to erase the events leading to her
family's murder courtney's mission was
to travel to the year 1951 and recruit
ted knight the original star man but
unfortunately he was committed to an
insane asylum at that point in time
before she could convince him that she
wasn't a drug-induced hallucination the
asylum orderlies spotted her and drugged
her courtney was strapped into a
straitjacket and tossed into a padded
cell luckily by jsa number 70 courtney's
time-traveling sister patricia managed
to free her while her time as a mental
patient was brief it likely remains a
dark spot in courtney's memory of how
superheroes are viewed by some people
despite the fact that she wears a mask a
lot of people know that courtney
whitmore and star girl are one in the
same her family the entire justice
society of america and even several of
her villains know star girl's true
identity as it turns out a lot of this
is due to courtney's carelessness she
once exposed her secret identity to her
friend mary on the night of her first
adventure as the star-spangled kid
sometimes the fact that practically
everyone knows courtney a star girl is
used for comedic effect like when the
jsa visits courtney during a dentist's
appointment other times however writers
remind readers that the reason for the
secret identity was so villains wouldn't
come after the hero's loved ones
something that tragically happens to
stargirl
i put all of us in so much danger
because i believed in some fairy tale
in justice league of america issues 10
through 12 courtney gets on the super
villain shadow thief's radar a few
issues later shadow thief tracks down
courtney's family wounds her mom and
kills her little brother although the
experience helps motivate courtney to be
a better superhero the cost is extremely
high and extremely dark
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]